burping is still far from safe and we
were taken into the town at speed with
armed guards
this is the closest the Russians got to
the capital just a few kilometers away
and this is where they fought some of
their most Savage Street battles the
fighting and bombing went on for more
than a month in parts of the Town
there's hardly a building or home which
is untouched
Ukrainian soldiers are still very much
on Red Alert here stop
were waved through but they're extremely
worried about any mines or traps the
Russians may have left behind
and this is what is left of much of
erpin what Terror must have been felt by
those living in these apartment blocks
as shell after shell came raining in
Mortar after mortar and heavy artillery
the place is littered with unexploded
ordnance in playgrounds in residential
Four Courts nowhere was off limits and
there was no mercy shown for erpin's
residence people obviously tried to pack
their cars to try and get out of here as
the shelling came in and you can see the
place is strewn with belongings as they
tried to get out but the shells were
coming in and hitting even the vehicles
as they tried to escape
they're still retrieving the many dead
here
the exact numbers who died will take
some time to confirm with survivors
talking of burying relatives and friends
in the parks and playgrounds during the
month-long bombardment
Ukrainian forces were not meant to be
able to do this drive back their much
more powerful enemy but they fought
fantastically hard European has turned
out to be one of the pivotal battles of
the war so far but whatever constitutes
Victory here has come with huge
sacrifices you see white-hearted
casualties that Russian
Russian troops have committed you see
the facts of atrocities usage of
prohibited Weaponry against of civilian
population and our national police is
documenting and collecting every piece
of evidence to bring them to justice
Wonder any of these people are still
alive and the last few to be brought out
showed terrible signs of suffering and
pain
have you got an apple he asks us he
looks very gaunt and his feet are in a
terrible State
most of the town's infrastructure has
been bombed so he and the others trapped
in the town had no electricity little
food or water and constant shelling and
fighting when did you last eat we asked
three days ago comes the reply
we found a few Hardy residents who've
managed to stick it out through the very
worst
this is just terrible so guy tells us
all that's happened here it's just
barbaric
it's the work of a human who's very sick
in the head
this small group have got through their
worst ordeal by sticking together
Ukrainian solidarity it must be an
absolutely incredibly terrifying to have
stated
she tells us Rockets were exploding all
above them do you feel safe now we were
just here she says just sitting here and
they were right over us
the near constant attacks have seen the
town virtually emptied with all those we
spoke to believing the Russians will be
back maybe to erpin certainly to try to
take the capital again and they have the
problem of clearing it all of the highly
dangerous Munitions too
it's an enormous challenge the capital's
top police officer
our Specialists have calculated the
longest period between Shillings was
about 21 seconds he said
and for the elderly we saw being
stretched out she kept her eyes tightly
closed she's so scared the ordeal is not
over yet
all their lives have been altered beyond
comprehension
but as we left those remaining still
showed incredible Defiance and fortitude
Alex Crawford Sky News inside Urban